um he's the host of his own hit CNN show
United shades of America it's amazing
you should check it out um let's welcome
w kamau Bell hey what's up come out are
you doing hey good thanks for having me
did you think cuz cuz here on the show
we want it we want this to be an active
and open forum for everyone to share
their experiences and thoughts but do
you think that you know what you've been
doing is is kind of what's happening
right now like I mean I I think like the
conversations that I've been having the
United shades I've been hearing all my
life from my mom friends of my mom like
I was I was a my mom's a single mother
which means as a kid you go everywhere
your single mom does cuz she's not
paying for babysitter's isn't the money
so I so I was always around a lot of
adult conversations and I was born like
a few years after the civil rights
movement sort of peaked and so there's a
lot of conversations about what do we do
next so for me this is just the
conversation I was always hearing and
I'm feel really honored that CNN invites
me to have them on TV because me and my
friends have these conversations all the
time but I know the CNN audience isn't
always having those conversations we're
starting the conversation in our work
family
how have you been starting the
conversation and your family about
George Floyd and the protest well you
know because I work for the news we have
the news on all the time we just had it
on before I sat down with you and my
kids asked questions I got a
nine-year-old and five-year-old and they
asked questions about what's going on
and the thing I think a lot of people
especially white people are afraid of
it's like I don't want to show my kids
the news because I don't know how
they'll handle the information or I
don't know what to tell them but for me
it's like just do the same thing you do
with your kid anytime talk to them and
answer the question and at some point
your kid will let you know when they've
had enough because they'll be like I
don't understand or they'll just walk
off and go be something else
but I agree so so many people that I've
talked to as well in the limelight not
aniline light you know they're afraid to
say the wrong thing you know they're
they're afraid like when and sometimes I
feel like that's happened with me like I
say something I'm like that is not what
I meant at all like that like wait what
like so what do you what do you say to
that like because I
I don't think people should be quiet
because that hasn't helped but at the
same time what if what if they're afraid
they prove any like what they're saying
is gonna be twisted I'd say don't be
afraid of saying the wrong thing be
confident you're gonna say the wrong
thing you're going to say the wrong
thing it's will step in to saying the
wrong thing boldly and the key part is
when somebody tells you said the wrong
thing go oh did I say the wrong thing
yeah I'm sorry
what is the right thing or tell me where
I can go find out what the right thing
is and I will learn to say the right
thing I think I think people's fear of
saying the wrong thing again white
people it then puts them in places they
never say anything which is why we have
you know George Floyd obviously it's not
the first person to be killed by a
police Brianna Taylor I mean we can go
on yeah there's 20 McDade and there's
the there's been people since there's a
black people since George Floyd who
killed by cops under circumstances that
don't make any sense
so but the fact is is that I think for
the most part white people because
they're not continuing the conversation
it's like every time it happens it's a
new it's like I can't believe that
happened you know yeah you have to
realize if you if you work had invested
in the conversation let's say if your
great-grandparents had invested in it
during when Emmett Till was murdered we
wouldn't have to be having a
conversation now honestly this whole
conversation is why we've started the
conversation specifically in our own
environment because I don't think I
think sometimes we start thinking of the
problem and it gets so big like when I
think of world hunger when I think of
black lives matter when I think of you
know anything I just start going oh it's
such a big problem like how are we gonna
fix it but I think if you focus in your
own small community if everybody does
that then that's where change can happen
because you start focusing you start
calling your friends out calling your
self out you know allowing people to
talk and actually listening like you're
saying like and I think that's why we
wanted to start start the conversation
with our show and being the change that
we want to see and I just want to thank
you because I know that you've been
doing this for years because I've been
one of your walk your viewer so um well
y'all look for a season five of Kamal's
emmy-winning show it's amazing United
shades of America this month on CNN
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going